six times a year these giants battle
each other for top placement in japan's
most beloved traditional sport
sumo
highly ritualized this sport dates back
more than a thousand years originating
as a right of the shinto religion
matches are a true window into an
earlier era
participants wear colorful shinto guard
stomping drives evil spirits from the
ring
while tossing sacred salt appeases the
shinto gods before the ring is sullied
by the wrestler's presence
what's surprising about sumo is the
sheer size of the wrestlers
a traditional diet that includes chango
nabe a stew made from fatty meats
cabbage eggs and bean sprouts helps them
bulk up
entering the ring girth is advantageous
the rules are simple knock your opponent
down or out of the ring
wrestlers slam slap
and toss opponents into submission
it usually lasts less than a minute
sumo wrestlers belong to stables which
function like clubs and are where they
learn the finer points of sumo from
experienced mentors
each match is an opportunity for sumo
wrestlers to move up the complex ranking
system
or down
at the top are the yokozuna or grand
champions
in the ring they are distinguished by
the large ropes around their waists
a match like this is a feast for the
fans
but no matter what their rank the
stylized battle of these giants lies at
the heart of japanese tradition